otherwise known as agent 13 sharon
carter is one of shield's deadliest
operatives
but what's the full story behind this
legendary ally of captain america
from her family roots to her most
dangerous missions this is the untold
truth of sharon carter
one thing worth knowing is that sharon
carter wasn't actually the first
agent 13. her aunt margaret peggy carter
holds that distinction
during her time as agent 13 peggy fights
in the french resistance
falls in love with captain america and
takes on the first iteration of hydra
naturally peggy is heartbroken when cap
disappears
however she quickly overcomes her grief
joins a number of different spy agencies
and eventually becomes an
agent of shield her older brother
harrison later welcomes a daughter named
sharon
and the two become very close in fact
sharon sees peggy as something of a
personal hero
having grown up dazzled by tales of her
aunt's wartime exploits sharon decides
to join shield
and even adopts her aunt's old code name
but then
peggy suddenly relapses into grief for
cap and is placed
into an asylum she becomes so delusional
in fact that she imagined sharon to be
her kid sister and harrison to be her
father
this strange plotline was introduced
mostly because of the increasing time
lag between world war
ii and the modern era in the end it
turns out that peggy is being
manipulated by dr faustus
but cap rescues her and she snaps out of
her delirium
cap finally convinces peggy that they
can never be together
although he conveniently leaves out the
part about him dating sharon
when captain america first meets sharon
carter she looks so much like peggy that
he actually thinks he's hallucinating
at the time sharon is on a mission for
shield trying to prevent batroc the
leaper from obtaining a chemical
compound called inferno 42.
they later reunite while trying to take
down aim and modoc
soon after she helps cap and black
panther bring down baron zemo after the
notorious villain obtains a death ray
and these are just a small handful of
agent 13's adventures in the silver age
of comics
sharon works frequently with steve
rogers during this era but
cap never fully embraces her as a
partner unfortunately he's always too
worried about her personal safety to
realize how lethal
and useful she can be it doesn't help
that he's
also kinda obsessed with bucky's death
at this point and
can't stand the thought of losing
another partner both captain america
and sharon carter flirt with retirement
on multiple occasions
always in the hope that they might
settle down together
cap is the first to consider this when
they're reunited for the first time
heck he even makes plans to propose to
her when he realizes he's about to be
replaced by a bunch of cosplayers
however he realizes that he can't hang
up the shield just yet
nonetheless cap tries to get sharon to
quit on multiple occasions
at first she's resistant to the idea but
she eventually agrees to take an
inactive role with shield that places
her firmly on the sidelines
later sharon regains her full-time role
with shield as nick fury claims her phd
and metaphysical psychology makes her
too valuable and agent to lose
sharon is subsequently put in charge of
an all-woman cadre of shield agents
called the femme
force there is a brief time during which
sharon decides she's had enough of
shield
and finally quits to be with cap not
long after however cap defeats the
secret empire and learns that it's
headed by a
high-ranking government official he's so
disillusioned by this revelation that he
quits his role as captain america
and when hawkeye talks stephen to
becoming a new kind of hero
sharon is less than enthused by the idea
you didn't see that coming ultimately
cap's decision to walk the hero's path
puts an end to his dreams of living an
idyllic life with sharon
even by the standards of the marvel
universe dr faustus
is a truly vile villain his entire modus
operandi is violating people's free will
to make them his mind slaves and the
subtle nature of his powers make him
especially difficult to root out and
destroy he manipulates peggy carter for
years
although he never learns anything of
much use
then william burnside the twisted
captain america of the 1950s comes under
his control
compelling him to become the leader of a
neo-nazi group
called the national force at this point
cap and sharon have been on again off
again for a long time
she's still mad at him for choosing life
as captain america over her and is busy
flirting with her neighbor the pacifist
dave cox sharon soon returns to active
duty and
ends up acting as a shield liaison for
the new york police during their
investigation of the national force
when she goes undercover however she
quickly comes under the influence of
faustus who makes her one of his foot
soldiers
during a battle against the national
force cap loses sight of sharon who is
later revealed to have self-immolated
alongside a number of
other national force agents for all
intents and purposes
sharon carter is dead except of course
she
isn't what a twist
it's eventually revealed that sharon has
actually been sent on a deep cover
mission in europe but
something went wrong along the way she
got completely cut off from shield and
ended up behind
enemy lines and it took her years to
make it out with captain america
convinced that she was dead the whole
time
now at this point in comics canon the
super soldier serum has begun to take a
toll on cap's body
just as he's about to die sharon and her
team whisk away his body and give him a
total blood transfusion from the only
other person with the serum running
through their veins
the red skull as it turns out the red
skull who has been inhabiting a clone of
cap's body for years
arranged the rescue because he needs the
real cap to retrieve the cosmic cube
the cube is being held by a group of
fanatics from aim called the kuba cult
a group sharon has successfully
infiltrated she puts the cube in cap's
hands knowing he'll use its power for
good but
cap gets trapped inside it with adolf
hitler of all people
of course he soon triumphs escapes and
defeats the red skull
cap and sharon are reunited and their
on-again off-again relationship is
finally turned back on
after the civil war conflict between
steve rogers and tony stark turns deadly
captain america decides to end the
bloodshed by turning himself
in on his way to his trial however he's
gunned down
by a mysterious sniper shortly after the
news of cap's death goes public
cynthia sin schmidt daughter of the red
skull corners a frantic sharon in a
hospital bathroom
she then tells sharon that dr faustus
has a message for her
remember sharon realizes to her horror
that she has killed captain america it
turns out that this whole mess has been
part of an elaborate brainwashing scheme
perpetrated by the red skull and dr
faustus
who installed a subconscious trigger in
sharon's mind
and used her to seemingly kill cap
thankfully it turns out that cap was
merely displaced in time so sharon
enlists the aid of him
and reed richards to bring him back to
reality
after captain america returns from his
time travel pseudo death
he and sharon become closer than ever
subsequently she joins his secret
avengers black
ops team and alongside a number of other
heroes they chase the serpent crown to
mars
battle the shadow council and uncover
the thule society a secret order of
nazis
then when peggy carter finally dies of
old age sharon capp and their allies
come together to mourn her passing
at the funeral however a sniper starts
shooting at them and they quickly learn
that the assailant is the world war ii
hero code named bravo
bravo was lost on an extra dimensional
mission eventually returning and
aligning himself with a new version of
hydra
cap is subsequently trapped in the
extra-dimensional land of nowhere but
sharon
alongside fury and the falcon steps up
to rescue him
one of the weirdest cap stories ever
begins when a mysterious subway car
arrives at an abandoned station in new
york
cap climbs on board but sharon doesn't
as it only has room for one
thus cap is whisked away to the brutal
dimension z an
alien reality that has been conquered by
cap's old enemy arnhem zola
zola seeks to remove the super soldier
serum from cap
in order to give it to his children cap
spends the next dozen years trying to
survive
even raising zola's son ian as his own
he creates an alliance with a local
tribe of monsters opposed to zola and
eventually leads a rebellion
against the villain sharon manages to
track him down too
as only 30 minutes have passed on earth
though zola's daughter jet black
switches sides to join the heroes
sharon is forced to sacrifice herself to
save cap
and the earth predictably however sharon
isn't actually dead
having arrived in dimension z sharon
takes over cap's role and raises ian as
her own
when she is finally rescued from
dimension z by the falcon
she and steve reunite for a while they
find peace and happiness together as
they coordinate the avengers but
generally refrain from going on field
missions
sharon has acted as director of shield
on a couple of different occasions
the first of these happens after she
embarks on an expedition into the savage
land with captain america
as their mission comes to an end a
tender moment between the two lovebirds
is crashed by nick fury who later
reveals that he's decided to appoint
sharon
as his replacement years later when cap
is replaced by the cosmic cube generated
hydra cap it's revealed that the red
skull was behind shield's initiative to
use a partial cosmic cube to create the
super villain town of pleasant hill
the red skull knew that the experiment
was doomed to failure however and even
allowed baron zemo to come in
and wreck it for good measure this was
the former shield director maria hill's
project
and as such she takes the fall for it
evil cap then pushes to have sharon take
the role of director
instead sharon recommends him for the
job with a proviso that gives him
absolute power in case of emergency it
doesn't end well
hey elijah
the secret empire event sees sharon step
down as shield director because she
thinks steve rogers is the right man for
the job
unfortunately for her and everyone else
a young sentient cosmic cube
named kobik has been brainwashed by the
red skull rewriting reality such that
steve rogers has always been a
deep cover hydra agent steve secretly
organizes an alien attack on new york
creating a state of emergency during
which he is awarded total control of
all armed forces evil cap is still in
love with sharon however
and gives her special treatment in his
new regime
he tries whining and dining her then
takes her out to a hydra youth science
fair where they see kids work on
surveillance equipment for hunting down
inhumans
when evil cap survives an assassination
attempt by black widow and starts to
doubt himself
he turns to sharon for reassurance
instead she almost dabs him
in the throat with a wooden stake
feeling a little peeved by this turn of
events cap puts sharon in prison and has
dr faustus brainwash her
unbeknownst to faustus however sharon
has studied his voice and techniques
and is now immune to them she poisons
him
knocks him out and uses cap's password
to bring down his
strike fleet helping to bring an end to
the hydra's reign and
ushering in the return of the real
captain america
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one